consider yourself invited to grab a
membership on my website joinpakman.com
one of our primary sources of revenue we
do an extra show every single day for
our members and you can use the coupon
code better21 to get a discount
i was browsing the david pakman show
subreddit this morning you can find the
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit we are close to uh looks like
close to 33 000 subscribers to the
subreddit it's free i'm selling you
nothing other than a good time let's
look at a few interesting posts i
spotted this morning one is are you
going to get the flu shot this year
user lyme guy
actually put up a poll
and the poll results an unscientific
survey of our subreddit audience
40 i'm sorry let's see here oh percent i
don't even see percentages here it looks
like it's about um two-thirds say yes
they are going to get the flu shot
um
about one-seventh or once about
one-seventh say no
and about a little over that say maybe i
got the flu shot this year it felt great
it really did i had i think my arm
bothered me a little bit the next day
uh otherwise no symptoms much much uh
much more fun than the covet vaccination
series let me put it that way i felt
pretty pretty lousy after that
um listen in particular with hospitals
very full with covid
anything i can do to reduce the odds
that i need to go to the hospital for
another reason
or that a member of my family needs to
go to the hospital for
whatever reason i'm going to do
and so
yes i got the flu shot i feel very good
about it um new data says you can get
the flu shot and the kovid shot
very close together i think kathy
griffin even posted a video or a picture
of herself getting them at the same time
um extremely safe
and worth doing so i hope people will do
it
another user says has david ever spoken
about subreddits like herman cain award
i'd be curious to know what he thinks
about a subreddit like this i'd imagine
he's not a fan as he doesn't seem to
indulge in the schadenfreude many seem
to in regards to the pandemic to the
subreddit at large what are your
thoughts on the herman cain award is it
doing some modicum of good by spreading
awareness or is the toxicity becoming a
problem users have gotten in touch with
extended family of the deceased
harassing them and some of the rhetoric
on the subreddit has escalated for my
part i'm a fan of getting people
vaccinated but none of the
aforementioned issues yeah i mean listen
the the doxing and the harassing family
members of those who died unvaccinated
from kovid yeah
that's a hard no for me
i do
have no problem with
and i've done it on the show
highlighting
loud anti-vaccine voices
who told everybody not to get vaccinated
and said they weren't getting vaccinated
and then they got covered and then they
died
not because i enjoy the fact that they
died
but because i hope that they are
cautionary tales for other people to go
and get themselves vaccinated so to the
extent that on herman cain award there
is cheering and it's called herman cain
award for people who may not know
because herman cain died of covet as far
as we know
and he may have gotten it at a trump
rally although
it's speculative it's not clear that
that's actually the case but that's the
that's the the reason for the name of
the subreddit um celebrating the deaths
i'm not a fan of and i've only looked at
that subreddit once and there was some
toxicity on it i won't lie but if we can
make um
if the death can become a cautionary
tale and get people vaccinated either
way someone tragically died
but it doesn't have to be completely in
vain if it maybe helps somebody else
another post i spotted on the subreddit
how can these folks folks like the
teacher david showed video of very
recently who make the claim that they
don't want to put the vaccine into their
body and how it's their right etc how
can they also simply ignore the option
for being tested with some frequency
instead the fact they ignore that makes
it look like they actually want to
infect people
what possible issue would they have with
covet testing as a replacement for
getting the vaccine what you have to
remember
is that they don't want to do anything
that is under the umbrella of a mandate
so
if the problem you're completely right
if the problem is vaccination
and you can skip vaccination with
testing then you say great i'll do the
testing weekly or i'll do the testing
daily or whatever is required by my
employer agency or whatever the case may
be
it's not really
just about the vaccine for some it's
about the vaccine but it's also about
not doing anything someone else tells
you to do
and so if you're being told you've got
to do one of these two things vaccine or
test
it becomes less about the vaccine and
more about freedom liberty i'm going to
do whatever the hell i want to do now
we've already talked about how your
freedom
to do something has to be balanced
against others freedom
not to be
uh damaged by your actions conversation
we've already had but it exposes the
fact that so many people who say i just
have a problem with the vaccine
also refuse to be tested or don't want
to be tested shows us it's not really
about the vaccine or at least it's not
only about the vaccine
join the subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit